[Music]
up next on book notes we discuss the
israeli intelligence community with cbs
news correspondent dan revive and
israeli journalist yossi millman their
new book is called every spy a prince
the complete history of israel's
intelligence community
this book
branches of the israeli intelligence
community the role each branch has
historically played as well as their
future roles in an area of conflict
potentially characterized by chemical
biological and nuclear warfare
[Music]
josie mellman co-author of the new book
every spy prince the complete history of
israel israel's intelligence community
who was ellie cohen
ali cohen was an israeli spy who
penetrated the iachalons of the syrian
government in the early 60s and he
provided israel with the best
information available
what was so different about his
intelligence activities what made his
story so famous
that he befriended the top echelons of
the syrian government including the
president of syria he became a friend of
syrian air force pilots and he provided
the information to israel and it helped
israel to win the war the six days war
in 67 and later on he was arrested in
ang by the syrians so he's
dead he's dead
yeah how did he do it
well he
he was of egyptian origins
he was born in
egypt
as a jew
later on in the
early 50s emigrated to israel as many
jews do
recruited by the israeli intelligence by
the
military intelligence later on by mossad
trained by them
received a new identity
from his israeli antlers as a syrian
trader
and he went in order to establish his
identity new identity
he went to argentina which
used to have a huge syrian community
and he befriended the syrian community
in argentina
got their trust
and from argentina from buenos aires was
sent to damascus to syria
operating as a as a legitimate
merchant uh but actually was an israeli
spy
dan revive the co-author of aries by
prince
what's the story about the israeli
intelligence community's ability to
steal a mig-21 from iraq
well what they had to do was convince a
pilot to do it in the mid-60s the
israelis are very good at cataloging
everything they possibly can
about the chief officers of the armies
of the arab countries surrounding them
it often includes air force pilots so
dossiers are collected by amman that's
israeli military intelligence about
everything they can personal lives where
they live looking for points of weakness
well they found a man called munir redfa
in iraq and an iraqi air force pilot
they found out that he wasn't quite
happy about everything among other
things he was disappointed at the time
or unhappy that iraq was bombing kurdish
rebels kurdish minority villages just
like these days it happens as well well
anyway the israelis approached him
through a woman they sent a female agent
to baghdad
uh she befriended him and it was uh well
what in the intelligence business they
call a honey trap she lured him to go
abroad to paris
you know come and in paris you can have
you know all my charms
and he did and he already was suspicious
that maybe she's an intelligence officer
but he was willing and in paris he
introduced him to israelis took him to
israel the deal was done
a million dollars shelter
his wife and children yes he was married
also were smuggled out of iraq and the
redfords
live in israel now new names etc got his
million dollars and more importantly
israel and the united states and
everyone israel wanted to share it with
in the west gotta look at that mig
so it's it's quite a feat considered one
of their best achievements
what uh what got the two of you
interested in doing a book
by the way it said the complete history
of israel's intelligence community
we met in london as a working as working
journalist
and
that was in 1981
after a couple of years in 1984 we
started the writing
articles for british and american
newspapers here for the washington post
most of our articles were dealing with
the middle east
with israeli politics but also with
defense and security and intelligence
related issues
sometime along the way we thought we
have a story to tell we are
writing articles about the middle east
about intelligence strategic
issues
let's try to write a book about
a story which until then i i don't think
has been told in to to the extent we
wanted it to be told
and we decided that we would try to
research for a book about
the complete history of the israeli
intelligence because until then until
this book comes out
other books had been written but
basically they are of glorifying nature
portraying portraying the israeli
intelligence as
supermen
not human beings
and we wanted also
to convey
the history of israel and the problems
facing the middle east
through the eyes of the intelligence
community so this book is not just about
uh the history of israel's intelligence
but also
to a certain extent the history of the
state of israel
and the history of the
arab-israeli-palestinian conflict where
were you born and raised
i was born in poland
but raised in israel my parents
immigrated to israel when i was six
years old that was in 1957
and
all my upgrade upbringing is in israel
i'm an israeli citizen i served in
israeli army i went to a
to in israeli university where are you
now
i spent the last year at harvard as a
niemann fellow at harvard university and
i'm going back to israel to work as a
journalist there
and by the way when you go back to
israel you still have military duty to
do every year
uh yes yes as a reservist
up to 30 40 days a year
dan revive where are you from
i'm a new yorker
born in new york raised in new york city
yeah new york city and my parents moved
out to long island where they are and uh
harvard educated but then moved overseas
got a job with cbs news as a reporter in
tel aviv
after two years there moved to london
where i've been for the last 10 years
with cbs news
we hear you mostly on the radio that's
right uh there's some television work as
well mainly radio work for cbs
when did you first get interested in the
intelligence story
in writing about israeli politics with
yossi writing some pieces for the
washington post and and other newspapers
and it was a repeated fact that a lot of
the information came from well from
israeli leaks from israeli experts and
we were fascinated as well with how do
they do it how do they collect so much
how does it work
but also from time to time came across
obvious flaws obvious problems i covered
trials in in britain
of you know israelis who were smugglers
or even a kidnapping case where the part
of the defense was we were working for
the mossad that kind of thing and it
made you wonder how much truth there is
in that and again we all could go to the
bookstore of the library and get a book
called the mossad or whatever and they
can be wonderful books but it's just
adventure stories that no one's looked
at it seriously that's what we decided
to do so no apologies for calling it the
complete history we certainly did our
best is 1973 and the surprise of the
egyptian syrian invasion the biggest
mistake the most the intelligence
community's ever made
um
yes in terms of its impact
on on israel that was the biggest
mistake and it was a costly one
more than 2000 israeli soldiers were
killed in the 73 war
but in terms of the most embarrassing
incident i think
that
the failure in 1973 in july 1973
to assassinate the right person israel
was after the leader
of a palestinian group black september
who was
responsible for the massacring of
israeli athletes a year earlier at the
olympics
and israel as israeli intelligence as
ordered by the prime minister then golda
meir
uh was after him and after his associate
12 12 of them were were assassinated by
the israeli
intelligence by a heat team selected by
the mossad
and
mistakenly in july 73 in a small town
lil hammer in norway
the israeli hit team killed the wrong
person a poor moroccan waiter
that was them and they were in some some
of the israeli agents were arrested by
the norwegian police
that was the the colossal mistake the
most embarrassing mistake
of the israeli intelligence other
mistakes oh well the 1980s is really the
troubled period not trying to dwell on
them but finding an important pattern
that that occurred as political control
became less effective so the invasion of
lebanon in 1982 a decision made of
course by prime minister bagan and his
then defense minister ariel sharonza to
go into lebanon clear out the plo but
based on faulty intelligence the
mossad's belief that it had formed a
wonderful partnership with the
christians of lebanon that they would
fight alongside the israelis and it
didn't happen that way and israel really
paid the price for that
israel's involvement in iran gate
israelis told by their prime minister to
take part in the effort to sell arms to
iran do the americans a favor it'll do
us a favor again very muddled thinking
in the background and we found that
mossad wasn't involved in it had tried
to stop it but failed to some
bureaucratic wrangling led to that a
nuclear worker mordechai vanu worked in
the demona nuclear reactor when abroad
sold many of the nuclear secrets and uh
the domestic security people shin bet
that's the equivalent of the fbi
shouldn't have let him leave the country
with his photographs of the reactor in
the end by the way that mossad had to uh
save the day sent a female agent if this
sounds familiar now to london lured him
another honey trap vanunu was lured
abroad to italy and kidnapped chained by
the mossad and brought to israel so in
the 80s again it was a matter of damage
control oh and one last one the shin bed
again that sort of fbi agency
caught torturing and killing two
palestinians who hijack a bus and then
covering up the fact so in the end the
shin bet director had to resign it was a
bad period the 80s and i even left one
out jonathan pollard
here in washington the
american civilian analyst at the navy
who was uh who was caught spying for the
israelis and that's been terrible
embarrassment largely because he was an
american jew
and we say in the book that the mossad
should have learned ages ago not to hire
jews to do that this picture on the
screen is that the picture of the
palestinian you were talking about yes
one of the two palestinian bus hijackers
caught by those are two shin bet agents
leading him away their faces masked at
the demand of the israeli sensor
he's being led away he's clearly alive
but later the official report said all
the bus hijackers were caught dead
because someone in the israeli press had
the guts to print that photo
the story came out that they had
captured them and killed them now maybe
if it had been handled
you know allah watergate with an
immediate apology by the authorities
they would have gotten away with it but
they kept denying and covering up
here's a picture of mordecai via nunu
that's right he's in jail right now in
israel yes serving 18 years in jail for
selling those nuclear secrets he went
abroad he said he was serving you know
the cause of man and the fact that the
world should know that israel has a
nuclear weapon but uh well i think maybe
the judge has actually listened to his
reasoning because if you will he only
got 18 years
i know i'm not going to pronounce this
right la cam yes that's right yes
that's the science liaison bureau or the
israelis called it la cam
which protected the nuclear secrets we
reveal that that was its real foremost
function but then ended up hiring
pollard the american here in the u.s who
spot for israel how did you and and
find out about lacombe when was the
first time it was ever publicly
mentioned um
over the polar defer
[Music]
until
1985
when jonathan pollard was arrested here
in washington
no one knew about the existence of such
a
secret organization not even in the
israeli intelligence community
it was the most
sacred
secret of the israeli intelligence which
is a secret as generally speaking
and when jonathan pollard was arrested
and israel had to apologize
for the u.s government
it was revealed that he was run
recruited and handled
by la cam the slb the science liaison
bureau
and many eyebrows were raised in israel
la cam we've never heard of what's that
it's a genuine agency or it was because
it was disbanded right away to please
the americans prime minister shimon
peres disbanded
who does the same job that lacam used to
do now other people in the defense
ministry its main job again protecting
the nuclear program and also acquiring
scientific and technological information
from around the world and there's no
question the israelis still have to do
that let me ask you about this book can
you buy this book in israel today sure
it came out in hebrew in israel and
quite modestly it is a bestseller in
israel as well how much of what you
tried to put in here was kept out by the
censors very little to be frank
i i think we'd have to admit it is very
little uh the chapters that yoshi wrote
which in effect came out of israel went
through the military sensor and there
was some haggling and uh there there
always is that it's it's fascinating
system of censorship you can go to the
center and complain why you wanted to
take out that paragraph and deal but i
think i have to admit i had to submit my
chapters to the israeli censorship
because i'm an israeli citizen and he's
subject to those laws but you also have
to admit that you know enough about the
system
that a little bit you censor yourself
for instance we knew that there's no
point you can't name the current
director or the mossad why try what's
the point so we didn't why why won't
they name as a matter of fact it's one
of the interesting things in the front
of the book here i don't know whether
james can get a tight shot of it you
list people who have run the different
agencies and and right there near the
one that's uh i can't see the day was in
1987
just last year the new director of the
mossad took over and in parentheses we
say disclosure forbidden by israeli law
what would have been the point i'll be
frank we could have had his name but
what's the point that's not the point of
this and i'll be i might land in a jail
yeah we'd mess up terribly
now under this uh
section here the commanders of military
intelligence amman you see a name twice
there that's now fairly famous hayam
herzog who is he and what did he do he
is now the president of the state of
israel
and
he came from
intelligence background he was
he was trained by the british during the
second world war as an intelligence
officer operated in europe after the war
he immigrated to israel
joined the israeli army
in 1948 and a year later became
the second
director
of israel's
military intelligence of amman
then he was assigned to washington to
work as the military attache here at the
israeli embassy
in 1954
he returned to israel
rejoined the army stayed in the army and
in
1958 once again was recalled
to become uh the chief the commander of
the military intelligence
brilliant military analyst got into
politics let's not forget in the united
states we have president bush who is a
cia director it's not quite the same
thing but of course it's a it's a test
of a man's metal of his patriotism very
much trusted did a great job in military
intelligence so people would
trust him as a wonderful reputation
prime minister shamir
also an intelligence background in his
case not military intelligence the
mossad the foreign espionage arm the
most famous of the agencies if you will
but shamir won't tell you exactly what
he did he worked in paris as operations
chief for europe
for a decade from 1955 to 65
and uh
got his experience of the world went to
lots of countries including some arab
countries undercover
i read somewhere and was it shimon peres
who is to fly back and forth and meet
with him in paris not with him paris at
that time when shamir was in paris
working for the mossad
paris was in charge of he was the
director general
yeah he was director general of the
defense ministry and he was
and perez was conducting his own mini
foreign policy
cementing
the relations between israel and france
in the 50s until the 60s france
was the major ally and supporters of the
state of israel only in the mid 60s this
role was taken over by united states
but i don't think that paris at that
time met with chamir that was
uh that if they did they broke an an
important internal intelligence role
that's the rule of compartmentalization
or departmentalization it means that you
should not know the names of your agents
or what the others are doing and you do
your own thing so to speak exactly but
all these years later and it's
fascinating in israel it is something to
be proud of because perez now in his
campaign appearances when he when he
speaks you know for the labor party
we'll always point that out that oh i
was involved in clandestine business as
well i helped make sure that israel has
a certain something in demona obviously
referring to the nuclear reactor or i
made sure that we were friendly with
france which meant a lot people are
proud of clandestine experience whereas
perhaps in america people would be
ashamed
and it was france who gave israel in
1956 1957
uh
it's its first and only nuclear reactor
right it's a big meaningful one there
was a little research one but yes yes
and so the future is so paris has
something to be proud of but
fascinatingly he can't reveal it all
either
we've been jumping all around here let's
go back to the beginning and get the
basics on the table how many people in
israel are involved in intelligence
activities
well it's it's a it's a state secret
nobody would tell you exactly
but we we believe that there are more
than 10 000 people involved directly
employed directly by the by the various
branches of the israeli intelligence
mainly the military intelligence
one has to remember that the military
intelligence amman is the largest and
the most important intelligence
organization in israel and
before the mossad before you get to that
i want to show the audience that that
how these different organizations are
spelled and explain them each because
you have three major
intelligence gathering organizations in
israel you start with the mossad what is
it mossad means institute by the way and
this is an institute for intelligence
and special operations so the mossad is
the foreign espionage arm compare it to
the cia all right go down here to the
next one is
right military intelligence it's a
hebrew acronym so it is the intelligence
arm of the armed forces as yoshi was
saying it in fact is the largest and
most important and then it says shin bet
two hebrew letters initials for security
services that's the domestic
agency the the equivalent of the fbi
which one of the three is the most
important
it would be ammon military intelligence
nothing is more important than you're
watching your arab neighbors for actual
movements of troops how many tanks they
have where are the aircraft
all these other missions that we
described are fascinating and even
getting you know thousands of jews into
the country is vital but
war
having a sign that war is coming that's
the key and that's amman's job which is
the second most important
the mossad the problem with the with the
with amman with the military
intelligence is that it lives in the
shadow of
the flamboyant mossad
uh
it can be compared to this to the same
problem which is facing
united states national security agency
nsa it is the largest the most important
agency in the intelligence community yet
the most the most famous one which gets
media attention is the cia the same is
in israel the mossad has become
sort of
epitomizing the israeli intelligence but
the most important agency is military
intelligence mossad comes
second and then you have
shin bet
the israeli equivalent to the fbi in
charge of
fighting
terrorism counter terrorism
subversion
trying to foil
plots against the state of israel
political plots and others
you tell the story about how you try to
find out what the
what they call the mossad when they deal
with uh publicly i thought it was a
reasonable question but the trouble is
uh you can't pick up the phone book
there's no uh langley in the in israel
that you can look up you know cia or in
our case the mossad we thought we should
ask what shall we call it in english you
can translate the hebrew words as i said
mossada's institute but when they write
a letter to their friends in the cia or
the british intelligence what do they
call themselves it took a while it was a
matter of asking the prime minister's
spokesman the best you could do because
officially
the mossad is under the prime minister's
office
and i think he sort of wondered why you
want to know and all that so we
explained and he came up with the
israeli secret intelligence service if
it were to have initials it would be
i-s-i-s
just simple words like that
interestingly enough kind of a british
model the british don't really like the
names mi5 and mi6 for their foreign
service they prefer s-i-s secret
intelligence service what was the
toughest bit of information to
gather for this book
i think about the extent
the involvement of the israeli
intelligence in
in a topic which is
very unusual for intelligence and this
is immigration
that's probably even more sensitive than
dealing with
arab military capabilities
since israel perceived itself
not just as a state of the israelis and
for the israelis but also a state for
the jews whenever wherever they are
so the israeli intelligence is becoming
the jewish intelligence
with
two specific
missions one
to protect jewish communities
uh
which are in peril
mainly in arab countries
jewish communities that are
persecuted by the local authorities
and secondly
to bring those jews from the countries
that they are not allowed to immigrate
to bring them over to israel
recently
the israeli intelligence was was trying
and he's still trying to bring over
ethiopian jews from ethiopia what was
known as operation moses
so that i think was even more
it was tougher than
uh talking
researching
for mossad or for amman
and there is a special unit
dealing with jewish immigration
who
first of all how do you become a member
of one of these intelligence gathering
organizations and who cannot be a member
um well the latter question's hard to
say they ought to be open-minded and
they might be but most of the agents or
operatives that they recruit are from
elite combat units people usually men in
the israeli armed forces who prove their
their courage and their
their intelligence their their smarts in
these units uh occasionally we even
spotted a newspaper ad which appeared to
be from the intelligence community
asking for people with military
experience and languages foreign
passport preferred for interesting work
abroad well it sounded like it was
probably for the most odd so maybe
they're having a little bit of trouble
recruiting which we indeed had heard so
personal recommendations oh it could be
through academic institutions the army
still is the key which of course makes
it hard for women by the way because you
don't have women in combat units you
have to be jewish
well no not necessarily actually not
even in the israeli army not not
everyone is jewish it's difficult to be
an arab muslim and be in the israeli
army but they have volunteers as well
there have been druze certainly you know
that minority that's in several
countries of the middle east including
israel circassian muslims it's a
particular group of muslims some of whom
have been wonderfully patriotic to
israel that's a matter of volunteering
as i say and there are volunteers
during a recent
american involvement in panama
i know at least in this network uh there
were tremendous number of calls about an
israeli mossad agent by the name of
harari
mike harrari fellow with a dark glass
fellow with the dark classes right here
this is mr noriega whatever happened to
mike harari and how did he get to be
this man's
intelligence assistant
my karari
was
an intelligence officer for many many
years
he worked for the shin bed
for the domestic security service in the
early 50s later on he joined mossad the
foreign arm of the israeli intelligence
he became an operational officer for the
mossad in 1972 he was selected by the
head of the mossad time general
zamil
to lead
the hit team which was after palestinian
terrorists involved in the
in the meaning massacre of the olympics
after the failure of
1973 in norway
my corarie was not
was not
was not asked any questions
the failure was swept under the carpet
and the intelligence community tried to
avoid the embarrassment by by ignoring
what happened without establishing
inquire inquiry committees to
investigate what really happened what
went wrong
and even maybe as a
as a prize as an award he was
given
a station
uh assignment to
to be a station chief in central america
in mexico
and uh
for six or five years he worked for
mossad for the israeli intelligence in
mexico city in charge of israeli
activities assad intelligence activities
in central america
that's how he befriended
colonel noriega
now in 1988
he retired he left the service he left
the mossad
started
started working as an independent
legitimate businessman as an insurance
broker in israel
he wasn't so successful
and he realized that actually what he
knows
is his old craft the intelligence craft
and he went abroad
and started working for colonel noriega
and became his right-hand man
on the day of the american invasion he
got out somehow
that's a very interesting and good
question yeah like we think the
americans could have caught them if
they'd really wanted to perhaps you'll
recall there were rumors on the very day
and the next day that they had caught
the israeli former mossad man who had
been orega's right-hand man
but they didn't seem to have caught him
because he turned up in israel and gave
a tv interview the first in his life in
which he said why is everyone picking on
me i was doing work in central america
i'm a nice fellow i've got my own
company here leave me alone if you keep
saying these things about me you're
putting my life in danger very first
interview in his life
at the beginning of this year january of
this year
anyway in panama
i can't say that we yet have the full
explanation but
we've concluded that it's more likely
that harare
like many israeli intelligence
operatives and in this case a former one
knew who's the winning side he could see
noriega was on his way down the american
soon to come in
uh he probably more or less jumped sides
probably gave the americans some
information probably was allowed to slip
out just beautifully easily got back to
israel are there others who used to be
mossad shimbet amman who are now
mercenaries around the world well this
is one of the major
concerns
of of this book we have a special
chapter called
business at all cost
a chapter which is dealing with the
phenomena that many israeli veterans of
the intelligence community of the armed
forces
are
looking for
new jobs as consultants
as trainers and some of them are landing
up with the most brutal regimes in the
world training drug dealers in
colombia
assisting dictators in
africa
working with the
brutal regimes in central america
and we believe that the israeli
government
must tighten its control over its
citizens
most of them are not anymore in service
they don't work for the government they
don't represent the agencies they are
privateers
we call them farmers
former intelligence officers former
military officers
they believe they that they
served israeli interests we think that
they give israel a bad name
the israelis have to learn how to cut
them off and or employ them or make it
clear who they are and who they aren't
and it's it has just ruined israel's
name in many places
is it hard to stay objective you've been
on this story what 10 years 12 years in
my case yeah i got to tel aviv in 78.
i
mean
i consider myself a professional fence
sitter and uh i don't find it terribly
hard first in israeli politics between
the labour party and the right-wingly
code i listen to both
there's a lot of sense in what they both
say and a lot of problems in what they
both say and then you get the
arab-israeli dispute so now i think i'm
a fence sitter and that especially for
this project it was important not to
bring a political bias to it because so
many people have great stories to tell
and if you just fit them together
carefully
almost if i dare say it like an
intelligence operative would do it's
boring work usually lots of little
scraps of information we felt like we
were pasting them together and making
sense out of it and then when we could
run it by someone
bring it and say is this the way it
happened if it made sense great it
wasn't a matter of politics we try to
avoid
political judgment we are professional
journalists
and this book is not about politics it's
about the israeli intelligence and we
have been trying to be fair and to judge
its
each incident on the merits of it
without any political bias
well let me deal with something that
we get from our audience all the time
you're an israeli
citizen
and
people that live in israel become very
much involved in the fight to survive
how do you then as a journalist an
israeli citizen
you know separate yourself from the need
to survive i i don't see any
contradiction between
me as an israeli patriot and i'm not
ashamed to declare here that i am an
israeli patriot i do believe that israel
has the right to exist and that there is
a pla there must be a place for the jews
and yet i can be
an
objective journalist
and that's what i have been doing uh
since i i left my military service i
served three years in the israeli army
like any other israeli i went to
university and since then for 14 years
i've been working as a journalist
establishing myself as a as a
professional professional journalist and
there is no contradiction as i don't see
any contradiction between a fight for
survival
and democracy israel is doing both he's
fighting for its survival sometimes
rightly sometimes
with wrong policies but yet trying to
maintain democratic values
and maybe it's a unique case in in the
modern world
intelligence service in israel you write
about
the last several years has the morale
gone down and has the
capability gone down
well any intelligence
fraternity is a reflection of its
society and israel has had its problems
some some might call it the problems of
middle age but
uh when i've said that before i've been
criticized by saying middle age i mean
it's going to die in 30 years i don't
really mean that but as the country
became about 40 years old it faced a new
set of challenges a brain drain this
affects the intelligence community some
of the best and brightest people leaving
the country oh questions about the
values of society once a charming
small
socialist country that you felt sorry
for surrounded by a sea of arabs and now
the world doesn't feel sorry for you and
all israelis have to contend with that
including israel's spies they don't have
the natural sympathy they had before in
various countries where they wanted to
operate in the past in scandinavia
the case earlier that we said the hit
team that got arrested the norwegians
did catch some but went easy on them let
them go i'm not sure they'd go so easy
on israelis these days so there's that
problem recruiting
not so much sympathy in the world not
quite as much sympathy at home either
because of the string of failures in the
80s not all israelis feel that
comfortable with their secret defenders
anymore so they've got
a lot of challenges now some hopes uh in
the last two years israel has launched
two satellites experimental satellites
both of them come come in since burned
up in the atmosphere there will be more
and the satellites in the future will no
doubt be spy in the sky kind of
satellites that will be a great boost
especially to military intelligence they
will feel they can now see the enemy
without relying on the u.s for satellite
photos that's an example really of the
technological edge the israelis would
like to emphasize and there are some
other examples of
israeli society
and its intelligence as reflecting the
spirit of the society is trying to
reform itself
the israelis were surprised
30
30 months ago by the palestinian
uprising
that the palestinian people suddenly
after 20 years of israeli occupation
said enough is enough
and are still involved in in a struggle
in a civilian disobedience sometimes
getting sore and very violent
and
the intelligence was the intelligence
community was surprised like the rest of
the society and the israeli government
they didn't believe that the
palestinians they would would be able to
do it they didn't see the palestinians
as a as a political entity as as people
with
national aspirations and yet
a year later a year and a half ago
it was the israeli
military intelligence in charge of
providing the government with the
national
the annual national
intelligence estimate
which
acknowledged
that the palestinian people are led by
the plo whether israel like it or not
its effect of life and israel has to
accommodate itself
with that political factor now that was
the military intelligence
the prime minister mr shamir didn't like
the idea and he still doesn't like it
but the intelligence had enough had
enough courage
to tell the government
this is effect of life you might like it
you might not like it but our job our
duty is to tell you the truth that might
be an encouraging sign because in the
past uh you know with the prevailing
spirit of israeli politics
intelligence agencies were just going
along going along with the old concept
for instance therefore not seeing the
1973 war coming not seeing the
palestinian uprising coming maybe
they're getting a little more courage
back now you're right that they got
caught in 73 because they got cocky
after 67 where do you see it today can
they can the 73 happen again in 1990
not really i don't think they have a
concept that the arabs would never
attack
they uh the israelis are far more
cautious now i don't think they're cocky
in fact what you see this year are
exercises by senior israeli military
officers including the head of military
intelligence who does talk to the press
the other agency chiefs are secretive
but military intelligence does i think
he's trying to cheer up the people there
have been a series of press conferences
in israel in which they explain though
not with full details that israel can
defend itself against chemical attack or
warheads that might be launched from
syria or especially iraq they don't give
the full information but it's almost to
you know keep the people's spirit up is
there a nuclear capability in israel
the official policy of israel is that
they never the government
has never admitted that israel has
nuclear capabilities nuclear weapons the
official line is the government line is
israel
will not be the first country in the
middle east to introduce nuclear weapons
yet it is worldwidely assumed that
israel does have nuclear capabilities
and uh i think it's my chapter maybe
no i i i think the arabs know it i mean
especially after modern kaiva nunu who
worked at the intelli at the nuclear
installations in demona
uh went abroad and told this story sold
this story for a british newspaper by
the way where is damona located in the
south of israel in a negative desert and
the caution you saw me express a moment
ago was just basically that it is a
taboo topic in israel it's generally not
for israelis to discuss
it's foreign analysts it's the cia for
instance who have a keen interest in
israel's nuclear program who've been
able to establish what they could and
much of the data that i was able to
obtain on that subject
came from foreigners because the signs
are there shipments of certain
technology certain developments that are
occurring
and
i don't think the israelis really want
you to think they don't have the nuclear
bomb in other words they want you to
think they do because that has a
deterrent effect
the iraqis are much less likely to start
a war if they think that they'd
immediately be destroyed by a nuclear
bomb and the deterrence well it actually
seems to work
you write
about saddam hussein before i ask you
the question about him uh when did you
when was this book
when would you put it to bed what was
the date the end of january this year
and you indicated here that saddam
hussein of iraq is trying to build up
the largest force in that part of the
world and become the leader militarily
and we've just experienced an example of
it
that surprise you at all what he did
with kuwait and the oil no
no i'm not surprised
and he might have a few few more
surprises in his uh pocket
um
can the israelis handle a million people
under arms in iraq well
it's a tough question
and the israeli intelligence the israeli
armed forces are very much concerned
about
uh
the size of the iraqi
uh army and
even more than that about its uh quality
uh iraq was involved
in the last decade in a bloody war with
iran for 10 years and iraqi soldiers
iraqi tank commanders iraqi pilots
acquired a lot of experience
plus that iraq has now very
sophisticated delivery capabilities
missiles missiles which can eat tel aviv
and israel is very much concerned about
it
just recently
the director general number two in the
israeli defense ministry
general ivory a former uh commander of
the israeli air force said that he
believes that israel is not prepared
psychologically and otherwise for the
possibility that for the first time
the next war in the middle east
if there is a war and hopefully i i hope
that the world will not occur
uh
israeli towns
um would be might be exposed
for the first time in the history of
israel
for arab attacks missile
missiles bombs maybe
air raids
all
previous wars were fought on arab lands
in the in the front and israeli citizens
civilians were not harmed
yeah ask you about money
again
if you were sitting seated right at this
desk and we were taking telephone calls
by now the calls would come in saying
the united states gives an extraordinary
amount of money every year to israel and
you'd hear figures all the way from 3.2
billion up to 10 billion depending on
how you
how you calculated i want to ask dan
raviv
how much money
every year does the u.s taxpayer
give to israel i think basically it's
the published uh grant and loans and i
know most of the loans end up being
excused of
3.8 billion dollars is where it stands
that's what the israelis are working on
to keep it at the very least at 3.8 they
no longer expect increases is that
including the the housing money for the
immigrants
probably not but those are supposed to
be loan guarantees aren't they and it's
not going to
exceed that by much even if it touches
4 billion because of some special
allocations because of special needs
there's not a lot of hidden money there
somewhere coming in with
in various ways no i really don't think
that there is you can talk about the
expense but i don't think it would be
right to of the sixth fleet the u.s
fleet in the mediterranean visiting
haifa harbor
but that's very much in the u.s interest
they really do want to visit the harbor
there they really do want to
pre-position
weapons medical supplies in israel
rather secretive don't know the full
details of that but that's not really
for the sake of israel that's the u.s
that wants a little pre-positioning in
israel i guess what i'm trying to say is
and i hear it all the time when i go to
israel they don't want to tell me
everything but they're always trying to
assure an american visitor such as
myself that it's worth it the u.s you
guys are getting the value you are did
anybody come to you you'll see uh either
one of you as a matter of fact and say
don't write this book
no
no
did anybody come to you and say um
we understand you're writing this book
and we'd appreciate you not writing
about say the nuclear
uh bomb situation
well as
dan mentioned earlier
being an israeli working in israel
i know how the israeli censorship and
how the defense
establishment is working
so there there were certain elements
which i believe that would endanger life
so i decided i wouldn't write about them
like naming
mossad agents working in arab countries
i wouldn't do it it's really endangering
their life and it's it's not necessarily
to do it do you know that for a fact you
know who they are
i there were some well i i i don't know
all of them and and that's the way it
should be but
at least i can think of one case when i
self-censored myself when it when it
comes to that kind of information are
there any arab intelligence agents that
have ever been caught inside israel
oh yes but uh most of the attempts
compared with the sophisticated israeli
efforts to set up elaborate cover
stories and plant people in in syria as
we discussed and also in egypt the arab
efforts are kind of elementary on the
other hand of course those that are
truly successful you never hear about
but the people who were caught
not too impressive not that many i think
we only have about five cases or so
someone who came from egypt took another
identity moved there as a you know as a
jew who was moving there
the concern by the israelis is really
much more it has been with soviet bloc
penetration well now there's not a
soviet bloc but has been with with that
concern they've been on the lookout for
communist country penetration always in
the belief and it was a valid one that
the soviet union would pass along almost
everything it learned to syria or at
some times to egypt in other words to
israel's enemies so they're on the
lookout for soviet agents they still are
we have
ten thousand and more soviet jews
moving to israel every month now that
gorbachev has opened the gates it's a
certain thing that there are spies kgb
spies among them plant what's the
closest that any uh israeli
intelligence agent i assume a mossad
agent has gotten to yasser arafat
[Music]
for several years at least
in the early 60s and
maybe even early 70s
top on the
israeli agenda he the israeli
intelligence wanted to get him
assassinated assassinated and i think
even uh we we talked about it in our
book even in during the war in lebanon
car
car bombs exploded near his headquarters
aerial bombing seemed to take place only
for the reason that he was reported to
be in that apartment and they missed him
and he's a he's a great survivor and he
survived endless attempts on his on his
life not just by israeli
agents also he has a lot of arab enemies
palestinian extremists such as abu nidal
syrian agents
on the other hand there is a question
maybe it's a more of philosophical
nature
which has been discussed by the israeli
intelligence
what good would it do if we kill the
head of a a terrorist organization
sometimes maybe it's it's better to
to let him live since
we can deal with the devil we know
rather than with the uncertainties of a
replacement
and i think that
the approach that is
used by the israeli intelligence is that
when you are dealing with small tiny
terrorist organizations organizations
which are
depended heavily on the leader it's like
small gangs
then maybe if you kill the leader you
destroy the organization but when it
comes to larger groups like the one that
is led by yasir arafat
it won't do any good by killing the
leader ben rave what's this picture uh
it's the other hand there always is
another hand in this business it's a
picture of a villa in tunisia
near the capital tunis where a mossad
team with
special israeli commandos landed from
the sea
just over two years ago and killed abu
jihad the number two man in the plo you
see that's the on the other hand it
wouldn't do any good to kill yasir
arafat so the thinking goes but to
remind the plo of who's really in charge
of the long reach of the mossad in april
88
one of the men who was organizing the
palestinian uprising was killed at his
home in that villa in tunisia
we've heard this name recently
there's been another book out on pan am
103.
here's a picture it's a strange looking
picture though yoshi explain why it
doesn't look normal
because
this picture was taken by a hidden
camera
photographed
of del camoni which was
uh right yes this one
this is del camoni the notorious
dalcomoni
it was taken by
west german agents trailed shadowing him
when he was in germany uh planning his
attack on pan am now it belongs in this
book because the germans were onto the
so-called alcamoni cell part of the pflp
general command a palestinian terrorist
group based in syria they were onto them
thanks to israeli tips the israelis were
also watching the cell wondering what
they were up to the conclusion reached
they wanted to blow up an aircraft
but they thought another aircraft a
flight from spain to israel was the
target so they felt very pleased when
the terror cell or most of the members
were arrested in october of 88 and that
flight was safe
but two months later the germans had
allowed most of the
alleged terrorists out and two months
later pan am 103 blew up general
question we've about out of time
what have we not covered in here that
you think the audience that will read
this book will find fascinating what
what elements of the book
i was surprised
to find out
uh what i would call the humanitarian
side of the israeli intelligence
and that's what maybe
makes the israeli intelligence so unique
and so special there is a special unit
in israel in charge of
immigration
try to imagine the cia or british mi6
are involved in that kind of of
of work
since israel is the state of the jewish
people so is the israeli intelligence
the jewish intelligence and he is trying
to bring over jews from countries like
iran from some arab countries
which don't allow them to immigrate and
this is a fascinating story it's a very
heroic story israeli agents are ready to
go to the most obscure places and danger
places in the world to bring over their
jewish brethren and what about the
history a lot of the history of the
mossad and amman and all that stuff what
did you find in the history of the
organizations that you found
particularly interesting lessons that
were learned and should have been
learned in the early years we start in
1948 with the birth of the state we
haven't discussed the title every spy
prince the the notion that god told
moses to choose the first spies 32
centuries ago to go into the land of
israel choose them from every tribe
every one of them are prince they were
supposed to be the elite and the idea of
the history in the upper left revenge
the first prince of intelligence what a
dedicated man mister intelligence the
founder of the mossad
almost unknown
and there in the upper right if it's in
the picture as well is iser harel
now he is known because he's written
books on the subject he was the head of
israeli intelligence for 10 years
emperor of the israelites
he made it into an empire and they're in
the lower left shoulder
one of the founders of israeli
intelligence interested in what yoshi
just mentioned
he was in charge of that unit called
revealed for the first time in our book
liaison bureau in charge of bringing
over jews from the soviet union and
eastern bloc countries in all the the
the book maybe this isn't a fair
question who's your favorite
intelligence operative over the years
that you uh wrote about
how fascinating it's hard to say yeah i
know i guess as a professional fence
sitter i i don't have a biting affection
necessarily you admire ellie cohen for
his ability to penetrate syria but then
he went too far kept transmitting on the
morse code key got caught got hanged and
you think that was dumb you admire
wolfgang lotz for doing it in egypt and
maybe admire him more because he got
away with it the champagne spy that's
what he called himself they remember him
well they remember him at mossad
headquarters especially because of his
expense accounts lots of champagne but
lots of egyptian officials loved him
who do you remember
uh i think the true ventiloach was a
very interesting person
he tried to
maybe imitate to build israeli
intelligence from scratches
build it
to model it on the british example to
bring british
spy espionage craft into the israeli
society
and uh he was he was laying down all the
fundamental details which later on
became became so
uh obvious so identified with the
israeli intelligence he had the
imagination to even know that israel
should negotiate with arabs last
question we are out of time this book is
dedicated to dory jonathan and emma who
are they my wife my two kids and to
billy and your tom my wife and lekid
the name of the book is every spy a
prince
the complete history of israel's
intelligence community our two guests
have been dan revive and josie melman
thank you gentlemen both for joining us
and to our audience
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
join us next week for a conversation
with roger kimball author of tenured
radicals how politics has corrupted our
higher education
this new book discusses the influence of
what the author calls 1960s radicalism
on the study of western civilization in
america's colleges and universities
that's book notes next sunday at 8 pm
eastern time
coming up next it's an interview with
british secretary of state for energy
john wacombe
[Music]